la promesse d'un nouveau rôle pour le
canada sur la scène internationale le
test viendra rapidement pour justin
trudeau alors qu'il devra plonger dans
les grands sommets dès la mi-novembre
les sommets du g20 et de l'apec suivi de
la conférence de paris sur le climat en
décembre
un agenda chargé donc qui le forcera à
préciser sa politique étrangère en tout
début de mandat
j'en ai discuté avec l'eau de la verdure
l'ex conseiller diplomatique du premier
ministre jean chrétien mais c'est la
vertu au bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous avez passé votre carrière au
ministère des affaires étrangères on le
premier ministre désigné qui va devoir
plonger dans ces dossiers difficiles
très rapidement on est en pleine période
de transition si vous fermez les yeux
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment où
ces affaires étrangères d'après vous
non tout est prêt à voir les élections
aux fraises ou aux coquettes peu importe
les particules
pire de la personne qui est en charge sa
transition c'est au fonctionnaire très
respecté de carrière comment est ce que
vous vous interprétez le signal qui est
envoyé à la haute fonction publique par
la nomination de cet homme là comme
responsable la transition
lionel amar 6
un jeune premier ministre qui a de
grandes ambitions que beaucoup promis
aux canadiens quant à la place du canada
dans le monde
mais la réalité va rater si on veut très
rapidement c'est quoi d'après vous son
plus gros défi sur la scène
internationale
comprenez
merci
comprendre
mais
m
c'est
mais quelques semaines à peine quelques
jours après son assermentation il faut
aller au g20 plonger tête première dans
le débat très difficiles de la guerre la
syrie les réfugiés et cetera la barre
est haute pour lui de préciser pour les
canadiens ses intentions à ce chapitre
c'est beau dire on va accueillir 25
mille réfugiés on va retirer nos avions
de chasse mais non le des partenaires
c'est là que ça se corse
lee
qu'est-ce qu'il faut préciser la dent
vous qui connaissait ces discussions de
coulisses l'on sait que ils vont
accueillir plusieurs réfugiés qu'on voit
retirer les sièges lui était qu'on va
faire notre part dans la coalition si
c'est assez théorique le si vous vous
étiez à ses côtés autour de la table
puisqu'il doit préciser la teneur
canada
certes madame
savoir comment
une certaine nostalgie dans une partie
la fonction publique surtout aux
affaires étrangères peut être d'une
autre époque sur le rôle du canada le
monde a quand même changé depuis l'ère
chrétien la géopolitique a changé les
forces en présence la complexité a
changé il faut redéfinir en vérité le
rôle du canada sur la scène
internationale
mais c'est pas passéiste comme vision du
monde
cette perception du canada du maintien
de la paix des casques bleus et chez
terra est ce qu'elle est toujours
d'actualité dans un monde d'aujourd'hui
où les conflits à l'étranger sont
tellement plus complexe tellement plus
difficile est chez terreur
financière
si vous avez été cher pas le premier
conseiller aux affaires étrangères de
premier ministre s'il y avait un écueil
d'après vous que monsieur trudeau doit
éviter alors qu'il entame son mandat
dans les plus grands dossiers de la
scène internationale ce serait quoi
non
les jambes
elle l'a été depuis quelques années
merci beaucoup c'est la verdure